Shure: 那个呢那应该也差不多吧
Shure: That one should be almost done too.
Jake:呀呀
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 我看着你的脸
Katrina: I'm looking at your face.
Katrina: 这个大羊排
Katrina: This big lamb chop.
Katrina: 这今天要做吗
Katrina: Are we cooking this today?
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Shure: 然后我再给他送过去
Katrina: 这是什么肉
Katrina: What kind of meat is this?
Katrina: 这是羊排吗
Katrina: Is this a lamb chop?
Shure: 那是猪的排骨
Shure: That's pork ribs.
Katrina: 他说什么
Katrina: 粗的是吗
Katrina: Is it thick?
Alice:猪
Katrina: 猪
Katrina: Pig.
Katrina: 鸡翅确实难烤熟再换
Katrina: Chicken wings are really hard to cook through, let's switch.
Katrina: 这个腌了只能当天吃完吧
Alice:放冰箱也没事
Alice: It's okay to put it in the fridge.
Alice:有的就专门
Alice: Some people specialize
Katrina: 提前一天腌
Alice:嗯放冰箱
Alice: Mm, and put it in the fridge
Katrina: 烤完烤12点还没烤完
Shure: 这些都烤了吧
Katrina: 这个你说这个叫什么来着
Katrina: What did you call this again?
Shure: 排骨
Shure: Ribs
Katrina: 排骨
Katrina: Ribs
Shure: 排骨认识吗
Shure: Do you know ribs?
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Katrina: 猪身上的排骨吗
Katrina: Ribs from a pig?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yep
Katrina: 不太认识
Katrina: I don't really know
Shure: 合理的吧
Shure: Reasonable, right?
Alice:感觉这火不旺
Alice: Feels like the fire isn't strong
Alice:炭要碎掉了
Alice: The charcoal is about to break
Shure: 没事看看你
Shure: It's okay, just checking on you.
Shure: 你为什么是转着的
Shure: Why are you spinning?
Shure: 给你看看
Shure: Let me show you.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Shure: 中看有点不中吃
Shure: Looks good but doesn't taste good.
Shure: 好吧哈哈哈
Shure: Alright, haha.
Katrina: 我来洒水我来洒水
Shure: 就是那些调料跟我妈那个放的都一样
Shure: The seasoning is just like my mom's, but it doesn't taste the same at all.
Shure: 但是就完全不一个味
Shure: But it tastes completely different.
Alice:避开肉点点就行
Shure: 还行这最起码就是挺还还算挺好吃
Shure: It's alright, it's actually pretty tasty.
Katrina: 为什么不能洒在肉上
Katrina: Why can't you sprinkle it on the meat?
Shure: 但是就是跟我妈那个味完全不一样
Shure: But it doesn't taste like my mom's at all.
Alice:主要是让那个水掉下去
Alice: The main thing is to let the water drain out.
Shure: 也不能说完全吧完全有点离谱
Shure: But you can't say completely, that's a bit much.
Katrina: 看看啊试验一下
Katrina: Let's see, let's test it out.
Shure: 就是感觉什么什么比例都不对
Shure: It just feels like the proportions are all wrong.
Shure: 这不等你回去吃去吗
Shure: Aren't you waiting to go home and eat?
Shure: 别别到时候我妈一紧张
Shure: Don't, don't, my mom gets nervous.
Shure: 然后也也放不明白了
Shure: And then, I can't figure it out either.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
Shure: 哪个啊那个小群
Shure: Which one? That small group?
Shure: 查物那个群啊
Shure: The group for checking items?
Lucia: 这些杯子是随便哪一个用都行的
Lucia: Any of these cups will do.
Katrina: 有一个是我的
Katrina: One of them is mine.
Lucia: 哪一个呀
Lucia: Which one?
Katrina: 啊我看看这是我的
Lucia: 啊好的
Shure: 就是脑袋里面全只想这一件事了
Shure: It's just that all you think about is this one thing.
Lucia: 喝上口再进去弄那个蛋糕
Lucia: Take a sip and then go back to work on the cake.
Katrina: 蛋糕做到哪一步了
Katrina: How far along is the cake?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 现在用刮刀刮上了奶油
Lucia: Now use the spatula to spread the cream.
Lucia: 要进去看一眼吗
Lucia: Want to take a look inside?
Katrina: 我去看看
Lucia: 杨老板在刮
Lucia: Jake is spreading it.
Lucia: 我觉得挺不错的
Lucia: I think it's pretty good.
Lucia: 本来是我刮来着
Lucia: I was supposed to spread it.
Lucia: 但是他这个
Lucia: But this guy...
Lucia: 呵呵水平非常高超
Lucia: Haha, he's really skilled.
Katrina: 看听说你的水平很高超
Katrina: Look, I heard you're really skilled.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How is it?
Jake:是像吗哈哈
Jake: Does it look like it? Haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈像
Katrina: Hahaha, it does.
Lucia: 像不像那个
Lucia: Does it look like...
Lucia: 就是哈利波特里面
Lucia: Like in Harry Potter...
Lucia: 海格给哈利做的那个蛋糕
Lucia: The cake Hagrid made for Harry.
Katrina: 对啊对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Jake:就照着那个做的
Tasha: 好了吗
Jake:好了
Lucia: 巧克力粉吗
Lucia: Is it chocolate powder?
Jake:画龙点睛画蛇点睛
Jake: Adding the finishing touch.
Tasha: Nice到底想说什么
Jake:就就牛逼牛逼好哈
Jake: This is awesome, awesome, good, haha.
Lucia: 这俩词完全是不同的意思啊
Lucia: These two words have totally different meanings!
Tasha: 我还以为是画蛇添足呢
Lucia: 你可考虑好
Lucia: You better think it through.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Katrina: 厉害
Lucia: 神来之笔
Lucia: Brilliant idea!
Jake:是
Katrina: 你有开甜品店吗
Tasha: 啊嗯
Katrina: 我就说很熟练
Katrina: 嗯拍张照
Lucia: 拍照拍照
Lucia: Take a photo, take a photo.
Katrina: 还要洒粉吗
Lucia: 嗯我手机撂哪去了
Tasha: 哦这里面还有一个袋子我说怎么倒不出来
Shure: 杨老板回个头
Shure: Jake, turn around.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 很棒
Shure: Great.
Tasha: 为啥呀差别很大吗
Shure: 这是我的被美女包围的室友们
Shure: These are my roommates surrounded by beauties.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey.
Katrina: 掉了掉
Katrina: It's falling, falling.
Shure: 然后这个就是
Shure: And this is...
Katrina: 滑下来了怎么了
Katrina: It's slipping down, what's wrong?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:好我来拯救他
Jake: Okay, I'll save him.
Tasha: 行行
Jake:我也觉得行
Jake: I think it's good too.
Lucia: 行行
Lucia: 行行好拜拜
Shure: 然后刚刚卡了一瓶起泡酒
Shure: And just now, we got a bottle of sparkling wine.
Tasha: 我在做蛋糕呢
Tasha: 嗯我晚点跟你说
Tasha: 你先发给我吧好拜拜
Tasha: 这么忙
Tasha: 对有点紧急情况
Tasha: 他们明天答辩
Jake:哦
Katrina: 好香啊
Tasha: 好了
Katrina: 当当当当
Katrina: Ta-da!
Katrina: 给个特写
Katrina: Give it a close-up.
Tasha: 杨老师做的真好看
Tasha: 切吧
Shure: 给你看看作者
Shure: Let me show you the author.
Tasha: 你可以用这个切
Tasha: You can use this to cut.
Shure: 来杨老板
Shure: Come on, Jake.
Shure: 切切切这历史性的一刀吧
Shure: Make this historic cut.
Jake:怎么切切
Jake: How do I cut it?
Tasha: 随便你啊
Tasha: However you want.
Tasha: 你想怎么切就怎么切
Tasha: Cut it however you like.
Shure: 你看5个就不好切
Shure: You see, five pieces are hard to cut.
Shure: 这这时候就就可以问AI一个问题
Shure: At this point, you can ask AI a question.
Shure: 我们放几个他更好切一些
Shure: How many pieces should we have for easier cutting?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 哈哈怎么能嫌弃我呢
Shure: Haha, how can you dislike me?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哎后面这个小心
Lucia: Hey, be careful in the back.
Shure: 留点面子留点面子
Shure: Give me some face, give me some face.
Shure: 免提呢免提呢
Shure: Hands-free, hands-free.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Shure: 来来来杨老板吃串
Shure: Come on, Jake, have a skewer.
Jake:好没手了
Jake: Okay, no hands.
Jake:没关系好谢谢你
Jake: It's okay, thank you.
Jake:不敢下手
Jake: I don't dare to cut.
Shure: 历史性的一刀
Shure: Historic cut.
Shure: 哎呀妈呀
Shure: Oh my gosh.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎呀妈呀哈哈
Lucia: Oh my gosh, haha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 好像没给这盘子剁碎了然后把
Shure: It seems like we didn't chop the plate into pieces.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈快刀斩乱麻
Lucia: Hahaha, quick cut to solve the problem.
Shure: 哎呀我天呐
Shure: Oh my goodness.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈好好好
Shure: Hahaha, alright, alright, alright.
Katrina: 爆浆了
Tasha: 我靠
Katrina: 高楼大厦崩塌了
Katrina: The skyscrapers have collapsed.
Katrina: 紧急维修
Katrina: Emergency repairs.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈紧急维修
Katrina: Hahaha, emergency repairs.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 紧急公关
Jake:大楼要导致去拿胶带糊
Jake: The building is collapsing, go get some tape to patch it up.
Jake:我要不先切吧
Jake: Should I cut it first?
Lucia: 也行切了再放草莓吧
Lucia: Sure, cut it and then put the strawberries.
Jake:对我这个也抵一下
Jake: Yeah, I'll prop this up too.
Shure: 这就是我每天拿着300块钱的生活
Shure: This is my life with just 300 bucks a day.
Shure: 没有怎么捣乱了呢
Shure: Not really causing trouble though.
Shure: 我是给AI贡献伟大数据集的
Shure: I'm contributing great datasets to AI.
Shure: 就是让他看一个
Shure: Just let him see one.
Shure: 不是所以
Shure: No, so
Shure: 真的吗我
Shure: Really, I
Shure: 我有那么离谱吗
Shure: am I that ridiculous?
Shure: 有你那个绝对就已经不是人类范畴
Shure: With you, it's definitely beyond human capabilities.
Shure: 能做到了
Shure: We can do it.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 为什么不是
Shure: Why not?
Shure: 当然可以
Shure: Of course we can.
Shure: 就是那两个手都不能同步那种
Shure: It's like neither hand can sync.
Shure: 嗯你
Shure: Hmm, you.
Shure: 你还好意思问
Shure: You have the nerve to ask.
Shure: 没事了问候一下看看你
Shure: No worries, just checking in on you.
Shure: 你用iPad
Shure: You're using an iPad.
Shure: 就是一整张屏幕都是我这张嘴是吧
Shure: So the whole screen is just my mouth, right?
Shure: 不现在不敢说话骂我
Shure: Now you dare not speak and curse me?
Shure: 只能比手势骂我是吗
Shure: Can only use gestures to curse me, right?
Katrina: 嗯你有两个哦你把它横过来了
Katrina: 往那边扇一般是
Katrina: 都可以
Katrina: It's all good.
Shure: 哎呦怎么了
Shure: Oh, what's up?
Katrina: 小蛋糕来喽
Katrina: The cake is here.
Shure: 他不理我
Shure: He's ignoring me.
Shure: 杨老板怎么开始夺布了
Shure: Why did Jake start snatching the fabric?
Jake:为等饭吃
Jake: Waiting to eat.
Shure: 饭大大厨
Shure: The big chef.
Shure: 大厨怎么样啊大厨
Shure: How's the big chef?
Shure: 铺满然后大概而且要要要铺高一点
Shure: Spread it out and also it needs to be a bit higher.
Jake:好再打碎
Jake: Okay, break it again.
Jake:没电了
Jake: No power.
Lucia: 认领一双筷子
Lucia: Claiming a pair of chopsticks.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 你知道我点这个炭点了多久吗
Shure: 本来7点多肉就演好了
Shure: Originally, the meat was ready at around 7.
Shure: 看我的室友们在干嘛
Shure: Look at what my roommates are doing.
Katrina: 刷朋友圈
Shure: 打个招呼吧
Shure: Say hello.
Katrina: 哈喽
Katrina: Hello.
Katrina: 过两天就可以跟你见面了哈
Katrina: We can meet in a few days, okay?
Shure: 你听到了吗
Shure: Did you hear that?
Shure: 每天都让你模拟大便
Shure: Every day you simulate defecation.
Shure: 好吧哈哈哈
Shure: Alright, hahaha.
Shure: 分身是吧
Shure: A clone, right?
Shure: 怎么他小名也叫楠楠
Shure: His nickname is also Nan Nan?
Shure: 那你叫什么
Shure: So what do you go by?
Shure: 叫北北是吗
Shure: Is it Beibei?
Shure: 大草莓
Shure: Big Strawberry.
Shure: 嗯他是黄
Shure: Yeah, it's yellow.
Shure: 不是他是黄油
Shure: No, it's butter.
Shure: 他是奶油
Shure: It's cream.
Shure: 跟咱俩那天买的那个是一样的
Shure: It's the same as the one we bought that day.
Shure: 就是那个带黄油味的那个
Shure: It's the one with the butter flavor.
Shure: 啊对海盐的那个
Shure: Oh right, the sea salt one.
Shure: 认识四年了头一回打视频是吧
Shure: We've known each other for four years, this is our first video call, right?
Alice:家人盘子可以拿过来了
Shure: 大一的时候都没打过是吧
Shure: We never did this in our freshman year, right?
Shure: 好像是吧
Shure: Seems like it.
Alice:把它们叫出来
Alice: Get them out.
Alice:可以吃了
Alice: We can eat.
Katrina: 他们在里面干啥
Alice:每个人分一点点吧
Alice: Everyone take a little bit.
Shure: 那时候不羞涩吗
Shure: Not shy back then?
Shure: 你不要做那青蛙表情
Shure: Don't make that frog face.
Katrina: 尝两口然后端进去
Katrina: Take a few bites and then bring it in.
Katrina: 你已经在吃蛋糕了
Katrina: You're already eating the cake.
Shure: 你可以把它剪一下吗
Shure: Can you cut it a bit?
Shure: 就是把这个大的剪刀剪
Shure: Just use the big scissors to cut it.
Katrina: 剪刀在哪呀
Katrina: Where are the scissors?
Shure: 那不用的了
Shure: Then we don't need it anymore.
Katrina: 这要洗一下不
Katrina: Do we need to wash this?
Shure: 是一直剪熟肉的
Shure: 我帮你我帮你夹一下来
Shure: Let me help you, let me clip it.
Katrina: 嗯你夹起来
Shure: 他其实应该再剪碎一点
Shure: Actually, they should be cut even smaller.
Katrina: 还要剪碎一点
Katrina: Cut them even smaller.
Shure: 你哎没事挺好挺好
Shure: Oh, it's fine, it's fine.
Shure: 这个这个再见
Shure: This, this, goodbye.
Shure: 你从你先从底下剪然后这样
Shure: You cut from the bottom first, and then like this.
Shure: 我不就一可以一直可以夹着吗
Shure: I can always hold it, right?
Shure: 学费了吗
Shure: Did you pay the tuition?
Katrina: 嗯
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Alice:你们可以先吃一点点
Alice: You guys can eat a little first.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 你在看什么
Shure: What are you looking at?
Jake:吃什么
Jake: What to eat?
Alice:在那个盘里
Alice: In that plate.
Alice:我夹过去了
Alice: I already clipped it over.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Alice:杨老板你是不是饿了
Alice: Jake, are you hungry?
Jake:呃呃还行还行
Jake: Uh, I'm okay, I'm okay.
Katrina: 在这
Jake:好了我来领
Jake: Alright, I'll get them.
Jake:有多的碗吗
Jake: Do we have extra bowls?
Jake:没有好的好的
Jake: No? Okay, okay.
Katrina: 没有直接上筷子吧
Katrina: No, just use chopsticks directly.
Shure: 就每天带着这眼镜不敢摘
Shure: I wear these glasses every day and don't dare take them off.
Shure: 摘了就像裸奔一样
Shure: Without them, it feels like I'm running around naked.
Shure: 哦今天洗脸的时候你知道吗
Shure: Oh, today when I was washing my face, you know?
Shure: 那个就是眼睛能看清
Shure: That's when your eyes can see clearly.
Shure: 就以为自己还戴着眼镜
Shure: And you think you're still wearing glasses.
Shure: 然后就手下意识这样一下
Shure: And then your hand instinctively goes like this.
Shure: 结果发现什么都没抓到
Shure: But you find nothing there.
Shure: 抓到空气
Shure: Grabbed air.
Shure: 就特不适应
Shure: Just not used to it.
Jake:就就叫这个
Jake: It's just called this.
Tasha: 我可以给它在丰富一点名字
Jake:嗯好的对
Jake: Yeah, that's right.
Tasha: 叫纸杯戚风
Jake: It's called a chiffon cupcake.
Tasha: 爆浆巧克力蛋糕
Jake:戚风是什么意思
Jake: What does chiffon mean?
Tasha: 戚风是指很蓬松的意思
Tasha: 我们刚刚觉得和话它就是一个硬
Tasha: 那个蛋糕胚子吧
Tasha: 它可能打发打发过了
Jake:哈哈哈好的
Jake: Hahaha, alright.
Jake:给他独特的风味
Jake: It gives it a unique flavor.
Lucia: 我来吧谢谢
Shure: 基本人都在里面吧
Shure: Most of the people are inside, right?
Katrina: 天呐我灯还亮着吗你帮
Katrina: Oh my gosh, is my light still on? Can you help me
Jake:亮着很亮
Jake: It's on, very bright
Katrina: 好
Jake:哦你们都来了
Jake: Oh, you're all here
Jake:好那吃吧
Jake: Okay, let's eat
Katrina: 这是给我们的蛋糕吗
Shure: 人类在远程沟通了一些方式
Shure: Humans have developed some ways to communicate remotely
Alice:这是不有孜然呀
Shure: 真的我觉得应该跟你在这看色之前
Shure: Really, I think before watching the color here
Katrina: 孜然粉就是在里面
Katrina: Cumin powder is just inside
Shure: 每天远程当我的数据集
Shure: Every day, remotely, for my dataset
Lucia: 我觉得我其实已经不太用得到筷子了
Lucia: I think I don't really need chopsticks anymore
Alice:那个是啥啊
Katrina: 嗯
Alice:那个
Shure: 你看我你还嫌我话多
Shure: Look at me, and you still think I talk too much
Shure: 嗯好好好
Shure: Okay, fine, fine
Shure: 不说了行了吧
Shure: I won't say anything, okay?
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Shure: 他为什么会有突然有个大拇指的标志
Shure: Why does he suddenly have a thumbs-up sign?
Shure: 是这个能能能
Shure: Is this... can... can...
Shure: 出什么效果吗之类的
Shure: Does it have any effect or something?
Shure: 哦这其实是加了的
Shure: Oh, this actually has been added.
Shure: 有那个回应
Shure: There's that response.
Shure: 他可能看不见我感觉
Shure: He might not be able to see, I feel.
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 还有什么
Shure: What else?
Shure: 这这样可以吗
Shure: Is this okay?
Shure: 这样可以吗
Shure: 哈哈哈他给我标过数据吗
Shure: Hahaha, did he ever mark data for me?
Jake:嗨
Jake:他给我标过数据吗
Jake: Did he mark data for me?
Shure: 他没给你标过数据
Shure: He didn't mark data for you.
Jake:好的
Shure: 他他
Shure: He, he...
Shure: 到时候可以来帮标数据
Shure: He can help mark the data later.
Katrina: 嗯好香啊
Katrina: Mmm, it smells so good.
Katrina: 放柠檬是吗这小蛋糕里面
Jake:唉有吗柠檬
Jake: Hey, is there any lemon?
Lucia: 什么柠檬
Lucia: What lemon?
Katrina: 好像
Lucia: 柠檬放了一点应该
Lucia: Should have put a bit.
Jake:噢对一开始给了一点
Jake: Oh right, added a bit at the beginning.
Shure: 大概打哪是什么
Shure: About where, what is it?
Shure: 哪是什么哪是什么这种的标签吧
Shure: Where, what, such labels.
Tasha: 你怎么半途而废了打奶油呢
Lucia: 等会让我再吃两口再回去打
Lucia: Let me eat a bit more before I go back to tagging.
Lucia: 还像刚打到刚才那种程度好了
Lucia: Still like the level we just hit earlier.
Shure: 哈哈你倒是可以打
Shure: Haha, you can hit it.
Shure: 然后就是到我这个人的轮廓的时候
Shure: And then when it comes to my character's outline.
Jake:这些筷子我就洗一下用
Shure: 人家都打human
Shure: They're all playing human.
Alice:那一块都是生的
Shure: 然后到我这打那个智力低下怎么说
Shure: But when it comes to me, they play the low intelligence one, what do you say?
Tasha: 哪个
Jake:这些都是生的是吧
Jake: These are all raw, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yep.
Jake:哦那我还是拿几个出来
Jake: Oh, then I'll still take a few out.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina: 这这是熟
Katrina: 这可以用
Katrina: This one can be used.
Jake:这个是新的
Jake: This one is new.
Katrina: 这干净
Katrina: This is clean.
Jake:那你们领
Jake: Then you guys take.
Jake:你们拿一个
Jake: You guys take one.
Jake:我还是洗两个
Jake:洗两双出来
Jake:你们领一双吧
Jake: You guys take a pair.
Tasha: 这是谁的吗
Katrina: 这是新的
Tasha: 啊是吗看不出来它很新
Jake:我再洗三双吧
Katrina: 要不然你们直接拿新的吧
Lucia: 也行我把这个先放回去然后
Lucia: Alright, I'll put this back first and then...
Shure: 还好有点主食
Shure: Good thing there's some staple food.
Shure: 不然的话这肉等到现在都他妈饿死了
Shure: Otherwise, we would've starved waiting for the meat till now.
Shure: 你要胃疼的话你要不先吃点药吧
Shure: If your stomach hurts, why don't you take some medicine first?
Shure: 你说话能不能别带妈
Shure: Can you stop using 'mom' in your speech?
Shure: 你平时带的少了是吗
Shure: Do you not use it often?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 好好好怎么
Shure: Okay, okay, how
Shure: 为回家
Shure: 开始规规范自己的说话了是吗
Shure: Are you starting to regulate your speech because you're going home today?
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh
Shure: 打下地起就开始去
Shure: I've been like this since I was born
Shure: 文明的好孩子是吧
Shure: A civilized good kid, right?
Shure: 那聊天记录刚刚那条傻逼是谁发的
Katrina: 我来烤一会吧
Katrina: Let me grill for a while
Katrina: 你去休息一会
Katrina: You go rest for a bit
Katrina: 吃个小蛋糕啥的
Katrina: Have a small cake or something
Alice:没事我不吃蛋糕太甜了
Alice: It's okay, I don't eat cake, it's too sweet
Katrina: 哇这个好像真的要烤好久
Katrina: Wow, this really seems like it's going to take a long time to grill
Alice:看里面还是生的
Alice: It still looks raw inside
Alice:有点汁水
Alice: There's some juices
Alice:不过还好
Alice: But it's okay.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Alice:再过一会就能吃了
Alice: We can eat in a little while.
Katrina: 你饿不
Katrina: Are you hungry?
Katrina: 哦闻饭味闻饱了
Alice:芝麻
Alice: Sesame.
Alice:喜欢撒芝麻的过程
Alice: I love the process of sprinkling sesame seeds.
Katrina: 边是生的
Katrina: The edge is raw.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How is it?
Jake:可以啊哈哈哈
Jake: Great, haha.
Jake:期待期待
Jake: Looking forward to it.
Shure: 有什么感想吗今天看完那个3D之后
Shure: 她也对我竖中指
Katrina: 你对一个刚刚经历过感情重创的人
Katrina: You know, for someone who just went through a heartbreak,
Katrina: 看你们那种甜蜜的视频
Katrina: Watching your sweet videos...
Katrina: 真的是杀人诛心啊
Katrina: It's really heart-wrenching.
Jake:可以也可以再考考也可以
Jake: You can also bake it more if you want.
Shure: 给不到啊
Katrina: 真把我气的
Katrina: I'm really pissed off.
Lucia: 杨老板来切一下
Lucia: 裱花袋
Lucia: Piping bag.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 您请哈哈哈
Lucia: Please go ahead, hahaha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Alice:你把那个碳给翻个个吧
Alice: Flip that charcoal over
Shure: 碳给翻个个
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm
Alice:不过感觉快烧完了差不多
Alice: But it seems almost done burning
Katrina: 想我什么时候回去
Katrina: Thinking about when I should go back.
Katrina: 哎其实有一个那个事没跟你们讲
Katrina: Oh, there's actually something I haven't told you.
Shure: 什么事
Katrina: 就来北京还有一个计划来着
Katrina: I had another plan when coming to Beijing.
Katrina: 就是有一个男生
Katrina: There's a guy.
Katrina: 然后我想去跟人家那个
Katrina: And I wanted to express my feelings.
Shure: 奔现
Katrina: 也不是奔现吧
Katrina: It's not really meeting in real life.
Katrina: 相当于去表明一下心意
Katrina: It's more like showing my intentions.
Katrina: 然后在想什么时候回去
Katrina: Then think about when to go back.
Katrina: 要是要是失败了马上回去
Katrina: If it fails, I'll go back immediately.
Shure: 哪个学校的
Katrina: 北邮的
Shure: 咦哪个专业的
Katrina: 你知道当我当时第一天来
Katrina: You know, when I first came here...
Katrina: 我发现你们都是北邮的时候
我就觉得
No speaker:
我这辈子是不是跟北邮过不去啊
Katrina: 我靠
Shure: 哪个专业的哪个专业的
Katrina: 不说我不说好丢人
Shure: 没事没事你说说我跟你讲我应该都认识
Katrina: 不要啊不要
Lucia: 我还不知道他21号会不会来呢
Katrina: 要不然多尴尬呀
Shure: 你邀请的他是吗
Katrina: 不是邀请另一个男生
Katrina: 哈哈哈怪怪
Katrina: 事情怪起来了
Katrina: 哎这说来话长
Katrina: 所以我在想什么时候订票
Katrina: 因为怕没票
Alice:给我吧我现在强的可怕
Alice: Give it to me, I'm really strong now.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Shure: 这个票不是51的票其实都还好
Shure: 加油fighting
Katrina: 21号请他们来
Katrina: 22号我们还要在这待一天
Katrina: 23号24号回去
Katrina: 我也有点想我舍友了
Katrina: 卧槽不可能表白成功的
Shure: 怎么不可能表白成功
Katrina: 不可能的
Katrina: 怎么不可能
Katrina: 从来没有想过表白成功的可能性
Shure: 哪个专业哪个专业的
Katrina: 你今天刺激到我了
Katrina: 我EMO了你的你的幸福吵到了我
Your happiness has disturbed my conspiracy.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Shure: 她说你的幸福吵到了她
Shure: 你怎么没话说了
Shure: 她在背后说你坏话
Katrina: 我靠你别挑拨离间
Katrina: 你是最大的
Shure: 现在把我
Shure: 把我说话当埋噪音了是吗已经
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: 有点用是吗